Finanzcoaches aus der Wirtschaft
– seltsam, solche Schulfremden.
Doch die Achtklässler wundern sich nur
kurz, denn was die erzählen, ist spannend.
Wie sollen die Schüler später nach dem
Abitur ihren eigenen Haushalt bestreiten?
Bei Mama bleiben oder auf eigenen Beinen?
Aber dann bitte mit Köpfchen.
Natürlich, sie bekommen Taschengeld.
Aber wo kommt Geld überhaupt her?
Und das nächste schicke Handy, wird das,
wenn sie 18 sind, wieder Papa bezahlen?
Vorsicht bei einem Kredit.
Wie funktioniert ein Kredit überhaupt?
Und das Brutto vom Lohn
– ist das auch das Netto?
Ja, also, ich find’s schon gut,
dass wir so was in der Schule machen,
damit wir auch irgendwie besser
fürs Leben vorbereitet werden.
Also, ich find, so ’n bisschen Gedanken über
das Leben sollte man schon sich machen,
aber jetzt nicht so jeden Tag so,
ja, was möcht ich werden,
was möcht ich alles ausgeben oder so,
aber so ’n bisschen im Hinterkopf
sollte man das schon alles behalten.
Ich versuch, gute Noten zu haben,
dass ich dann nachher studieren kann
und dass ich dann mit dem Geld,
das ich verdiene, ein Haus und ...
ein Haus und ’n Auto kaufen kann.
Leute aus der Wirtschaft wildern
im Terrain der Schule.
Und Petra Carbon, die Klassenlehrerin,
ist froh darüber.
Leuten aus der Praxis, so die Erfahrung,
hören die Schüler viel besser zu.
Ich find halt, Schule soll so
vieles jetzt können.
Wir sollen erziehen, wir sollen
Fachunterricht machen,
wir sollen bitte aufs Leben vorbereiten,
wir sollen für die Firmen vorbereiten
– ja, wie denn?
Irgendwo ist auch ein
Studium mal zu Ende.
Und warum hole ich mir dann
net die Experten rein? Ich bin ja dabei.
Wenn mir was net gefallen würde,
kann ich ja sofort reagieren.
Und die Kinder haben
definitiv ’n Mehrgewinn.
Externe aus der Wirtschaft hätten offenbar
einen Alien-Bonus, sagt Bettina Wende.
Sonst verkauft die
Rüsselsheimerin Versicherungen.
Seit vier Jahren ist sie ehrenamtlich
als Wirtschaftslehrerin dabei.
Ihr Wissen aus dem Beruf gibt
sie gern an Kinder weiter.
Ich glaub, der Ursprung war auch,
dass sich sehr viele junge
Menschen heutzutage verschulden,
bevor sie überhaupt eigentlich
fähig wären, sich zu verschulden,
über Handyverträge und solche Sachen.
Und dass man’s vermeiden will und ihnen
einfach ein bisschen an die Hand mitgeben,
wie sieht das echte Leben aus.
Doch es gibt auch die Sorge, Finanzcoaches
könnten werben in eigener Sache
oder Schüler manipulieren
– zum Beispiel mit Markenlogos.
Versicherungsfrau Wende
ist von der „Allianz“.
Aber die Schüler erfahren davon nichts.
Die Coaches verpflichten sich, entlang dem
„Beutelsbacher Konsens“ zu handeln,
heißt also, nicht die Schüler zu überwältigen
mit irgendwelchen Botschaften,
kontrovers zu diskutieren und natürlich
auch keine Werbung zu machen,
steht explizit auch drinnen,
keine einzelnen Produkte zu nennen.
Das sind die Kernbestandteile.
Dann aber natürlich auch,
die Schüler mit Respekt behandeln.
Am Ende gibt es eine Urkunde.
Ein eigener Haushalt, wissen sie nun,
kostet sie monatlich 1000 Euro
– mindestens.
Das hat sie dann doch erst mal erschreckt.
Zugleich lernten sie aber auch:
Man kann sich vieles selbst erarbeiten.
Allein das ist für den
Schulleiter ein Gewinn.
Wir hören regelmäßig aus der Wirtschaft, es
fehlen Auszubildende, es fehlen Fachkräfte,
und es gibt ja mittlerweile auch
die Bündnisse Schule und Wirtschaft,
es gibt natürlich die Praktika
schon seit sehr, sehr langer Zeit,
wo wir Schüler in die Betriebe schicken.
Es gibt Kooperationen mit Betrieben,
und ich finde das nicht nur legitim,
sondern sehr förderungswürdig.
Werden nun Kindern zu
angepassten Konsumenten erzogen,
wie Kritiker fürchten?
Am Ende hängt es wohl davon ab,
was Eltern und Schule ihnen
sonst noch so beibringen.